welcome to another episode of koi's
comic Conor good citizens of the reject
Nation I am very excited about this list
because it is one that we've gotten a
ton of comments about and remember if
you leave a comment telling me what
you'd like to see if we get enough of
them that is what I will make a video of
you or my co-host you are my producers
don't tell Greg that said this video is
only in the MCU we're gonna do the 25
best action fights in the MCU if this
video gets enough likes comments and
hits 50 000 views so share it with your
friends I do have already prepared 15 to
20 fights in the Marvel films we're
gonna do one giant list but then realize
that would be like another you know 63
villains thing it'd be it'd be crazy so
if you want to see what I think the
Marvel fights are outside the MCU we're
talking the blade Blood Rave we're
talking some of those incredible X-Men
fights some Logan goodness leave a
comment share this video with your
friends etc etc and please do hunt me
down over on Tick Tock 15 seconds 30
second one minute review I'm doing an
impression of Greg doing an impression
of me at this point either way let's get
into it all the best action in the MCU
all right we're going to start
because I wanted to keep this under 25
but I honestly had about 55 so one
honorable mention is the Thomas the
Train Engine fight in Ant-Man I gotta
give that some love there's some really
inventive fighting some inventive action
some great use of power so my one
honorable mention is the Thomas the Tank
Engine fight at the end of Ant-Man
alright now into 25 25 counting them
down starting with I think one of the
best fights in the MCU is the Sinister 5
fight the almost Mr six fight at the end
of Spider-Man no way home it's got a lot
of story in it and I love when a fight
is able to also convey a story so not
only do you see how the different
Spider-Man fight differently not only do
you see the different Power sets with
all of the almost sinister six villainy
but the scope felt really big I really
enjoyed that when you're leading up to a
giant reality warping event you've still
got the scope of all these villains plus
you've got this being a Redemption Arc
you see that they're being saved you get
to have the Nostalgia of a lot of these
characters you haven't seen fight in a
long time and you've got some really
cool story moments like Toby Maguire
fighting lizard that's kind of an Easter
egg for fan fans of the San Marini
franchise because they'd been setting up
a Tobey Maguire versus lizard fight
since Dylan Baker was in the early one
so there were moments that felt like
there were payoffs of long bygone eras
and we did get that incredible my
favorite moment of phase four Andrew
Garfield catching Mary Jane that moment
of redemption for Andrew Garfield
literally felt like Andrew Garfield the
actor getting redeemed his Spider-Man
getting redeemed him saving someone
there was just so much story in this
fight and it was a great fight so did my
number 25 in the MCU all right my number
24 is a bit of an asterisk because it is
a few fights but they're used as a
montage so I'm gonna encapsulate an
entire style of fight and it's in a show
you probably didn't expect to make this
list now I said MCU but thanks to
Daredevil being included in She-Hulk and
everything going forward I am including
Netflix in this list we have not yet
seen X-Men so it doesn't count yet but
in this list I did want to include some
of the incredible fights in Netflix
because to me that's some of the best
action we've had in the MCU I'm going to
say Colleen Wing's training fights as
well as her cage fights which were used
to establish what kind of character she
was are some of the best fights in the
MCU not only do we get to see henwick
actually kicking ass it's actually the
actors doing all this work not only do
we get to see some story elements
showing why as we progress she probably
should have been the Iron Fist but we
also get to set the stage and build out
the world we see the importance of
martial arts we see some story plot and
and emotional growth in the character
and we build out everything for Iron
Fist I think Jessica henwick is one of
the best things to happen to Iron Fist
and I feel like these fights along with
some of her great dialogue and some of
her great bouncing off with other
supporting characters in the show really
did Elevate that show say what you want
about Iron Fist but henwick was not a
weak point she gets one of my best
fights number 24. our number 23 is
Spider-Man fighting the vulture the very
end of Spider-Man homecoming is really
interesting because there's already been
so much action there's already been so
much tension we've already really had an
interesting thing where we like Adrian
tombs and we also like even more to hate
Adrian tombs we have this interesting
dynamic between like a paternal figure
and Spider-Man in he's the father of the
girl she likes there's a lot of really
interesting emotional Dynamics which I
think think elevates this fight pun
intended they're flying but also it does
the thing that Spider-Man comics do
great where Spider-Man is very good in
certain environments he is not made for
the sky he's a spider I love that not
only do you have him fighting vulture
who's clearly in his element he's
actually terrifying they do great work
with not only Michael Keaton but with
the character design but also he's at
the advantage the vulture is using his
skills so we get to see a villain in
their element fighting really well we
get to see the smarts and Ingenuity of
Spider-Man and we add an Avengers
element we add the plane that they're
stealing which adds more tension
everything else and also builds out to
the greater MCU I think that vulture
fight doesn't get enough love it's my
number 23. my number 22 is another fight
I don't feel like gets enough love there
is a lot of incredible action in Netflix
I'm going to say that over and over
again you're going to get sick of
hearing it but it's true this fight I
don't see on any action list I don't see
it any fight list and I really think it
showed how brutal war is in a one-on-one
scenario it is the final fight between
jigsaw and Punisher where jigsaw gets
mangled we not only get a new origin
Forge jigsaw we also tie it to
punisher's origin I love when they can
actually land the oh the bad guy is the
opposite of the good guy similar skill
set similar blah blah when that actually
works it's genius and this was brilliant
because it was at the end of the season
we built all the way up to jigsaw
becoming visually jigsaw we already
loved the actor Ben Barnes playing the
character we were already very invested
he's oddly Charming while being Sinister
but he's very much the opposite of Frank
Castle in that he doesn't have a problem
doing evil in the Evil's sake Frank
Castle is an anti-hero how do you make
someone a villain to an anti-hero they
got to be all the way bad so we've got
this war between these two professional
mercenaries we've got these two brutal
assassins brawling in a park and then it
ends with the very Carousel that made
Punisher born so from the birth of
Punisher we then have the birth of
Jigsaw he smashes his face into the
mirror from the carousel where his
children and wife died beautiful poetry
beautiful brutal action a very important
fight scene in the MCU my number 21 is
the fight on Titan there is going to be
a lot of Avengers on this list because
it's the culmination of a lot of
Storytelling what I love about the fight
on Titan is Thanos is just so hard to
take down you've got effectively an
entire team of Avengers and I love how
smart the movie was to kind of separate
and do three separate teams of Avengers
and this one is a medley of cosmic and
ground this is a medley of Guardians and
the Avengers we know fighting together
still failing to take out Thanos and I
love that this is a natural progression
to seeing just how powerful Doctor
Strange is after they do everything on
Titan after we see the power of
Spider-Man after we see the Ingenuity of
Iron Man after we see the brutality of
Thanos and after we have these
characters learning how to fight
together as a team in real time we see
at the end that Dr Strange himself is
one of the only things that even slows
him down that end with all of those
doctor strangers him being like tied up
in the magic all of the moment like that
it crescendos into and then a Star-Lord
moment of arrogance which is very
contested on the internet but is very
much his character that emotionality is
real and I think it actually suits the
character and the movie all of that
really feels like what it would be like
to fight the Mad Titan and I love this
fight so very much the Mad Titan fight
on Titan alright we are into the top 20
fights of the entire MCU this was one of
the hardest lists I've ever compiled
this might have actually been as hard as
the villains list because I realized the
scope of the MCU if there's three fights
per movie if there's 10 fights per
season we're talking hundreds of fights
so into the top 20 is crazy and I gotta
go with one of my favorite moments of
Multiverse of Madness it is where
Scarlet Witch goes full Scarlet Witch it
is a beautiful use of Multiverse in that
she can kill characters where
immediately endeared too because their
character we've wanted to see for all
time it's a great use of showing the
power of the Scarlet Witch because she's
not just doing finger guns it's not pew
pew pew she's actually using witchcraft
she's actually able to manipulate
reality she's able to do things like
ripping half of Professor X's face off
that isn't a head twist if you look
closely she rips one side of his head to
the left the jaw to the right she's
eviscerating these characters and the
Black Bolt moment is one of the biggest
gasps I've ever heard in MCU film so for
me I didn't love Multiverse Madness in a
the top 20 MCU way but I did love this
fight in a top 20 fight way and that's
what I love about these movies even if
there's not an experience that I enjoy
top to bottom there are always
highlights there are always moments and
to be honest if this wasn't a
multiversal fight it wouldn't have had
the same impact but because they
wouldn't have been able to kill as many
characters but at the same time it being
a multiversal fight also is tricky
because how much are you invested they
still manage to make me care while
walking that very fine line and bring in
new characters and show the power of
Scarlet witch in inventive ways love
this fight number 20. at number 19 we've
got the most James Bondi in the fights
do you remember in Casino Royale and
then Quantum of Solace have they started
using these incredible backdrops of
color and action juxtaposed with more
shadowy foreground figures and then they
move the camera around you start to feel
the dynamic of using the z-axis in a
fight z-axis is very important to me and
I think the z-axis use in the
scaffolding fight in shengchi is
absolutely genius not only do they go up
and down using the external wall of a
building using the scaffolding but
there's actually moments of depth of
field fighting not only do you have
these two Master martial artists
fighting in an aerial way without being
on rigs because they do have some use of
gravity and it's a fascinating way to
have a dance up down left right toward
but we get to see the power of Xiang chi
in an environment we haven't yet we get
to see just how skilled he is just how
World aware he is and we get to see the
incredible death dealer scenario that's
been teased throughout the film we've
been building up to this death dealer
fight this is a great way to show the
pros of two different martial artists
it's a great way to grow out the world
and it's a great way to see how you can
use a camera in very inventive ways
almost has its own character within a
martial arts fight when you actually
have stunt people and martial artists
doing the fighting less CGI more
Fighters and you get stuff like this I
love this fight next up we've got
another underrated fight from Netflix
this one is a show that had a lot of
really good political drama in its own
way and in the streets of Harlem it had
a lot of great character development but
a lot of people felt like and I and I'll
admit I'm one of them once we lost
mahershala Ali on Luke Cage the show
never quite felt the same this fight
however came matter nowhere and just
absolutely enveloped me in excitement
this is the bushmaster team up with Luke
Cage fight to take out all these drug
dealers the whole show you've had these
two guys at odds and again a hero and a
villain that have similar perspectives
but one key fundamental difference and
obviously Bushmaster very fundamentally
different than Luke Cage but in the way
they fight you get to see a lot of
characterization Luke Cage is a
bulldozer he doesn't stop moving he's
always going forward they even talk
about that with Pop there's always that
movement this forward momentum and then
Bushmaster has to tame himself because
he agreed not to kill for this fight
there's a really cool Dynamic of seeing
restraint plus seeing bulldozer plus no
death because this is a hero fight I
loved Bushmaster having to team up with
Luke Cage and I also love that they're
fighting styles tied into their
characterizations and any fight ever set
to Wu-Tang is always going to elevate I
mean this would be fun to just go
through all the Wu-Tang use in Luke Cage
but that isn't fair to the rest of the
MCU this fight doesn't get talked about
enough and it's truly incredible number
17 I often talk about how magic when
used in movies is really tricky because
it feels so linear one of my biggest
issues with Multiverse of Madness was
when Scarlet Witch was taking over and
fighting in kunlun it went from her
being inventive and like whispering in
that guy's ear like pew pew pew and I'm
like that's that there's so much we can
do with magic and Imagination and I
remember thinking that up until we got
to this fight and I was like this is
Imagination incarnate and I call this
fight the composer Supreme the music
fight between doctor strange and Doctor
Strange it almost went too long and I
think there is Merit in talking about
that but I think the inventiveness the
uh crazy orchestration pun intended and
all of the things they were able to do
to show that magic can be this force is
well worth the slightly I'd shave like
10 seconds it's just slightly too but it
is so cool it is so inventive you see
what the sorcerer Supreme can do and you
literally use music as a weapon like
what better way to have the composer get
to fight alongside Sam Raimi I love that
we've got this incredible score I love
that Sam Raimi is leaning into the weird
and I love that it feels Gothic and edgy
and inventive and Powerful all at once
which is Doctor Strange love this fight
number 16. okay so I'm a huge huge fan
of Punisher season one I thought
Punisher season two was good but not
great I remember liking it but not
loving it I remember Punisher season one
I could not stop watching all of
Daredevil couldn't stop watching there
are just some elements that that didn't
quite land from Punisher season two but
I would still put it up against a lot of
other Marvel content it just didn't
quite work that said the opening of
Punisher season two is one of the best
First episodes in the Netflix or Marvel
Cinematic Universe television show the
fight in the bar with Frank Castle
taking out everyone in a Barb brawl I
would put that up against Roadhouse I'd
put that up against any classic bar deep
bar room fight of all time this fight is
so brutal so intense so Frank Castle so
inventive it felt like the Jackie Chan
dream we always had of him fighting in
Home Depot like we're just use every
single prop but Punisher so it's
violently R-rated it's viscerally
R-rated it is so much evisceration I
love this fight I love the character
organization of John Bernthal and I love
that it immediately reminds you what
show you're watching and you're right
back in with one fight into the world of
Punisher it is a spectacular use of
stunts practical and characterization
all growing towards a great climax all
right we are into our Top 15. This is a
movie that I argue about almost as much
as eternals this is a movie that I think
belongs in the top third of the MCU this
is a movie that is maybe the most argued
about next to eternals and it's a movie
that has an action set piece that I
think sings above I mean this is top 15
and there's literally hundreds of action
set pieces this action fight is just so
memorable and inventive and crazy it is
the barrel of monkey scene in Iron Man
3. Iron Man 3 diving out of an airplane
and using electricity to have all these
people while falling through the sky
latch on together saving every single
one using science using geometry using
his brain and then using the genius of
shooting basically a free fall out of
the sky like that would be a huge thing
that Tom Cruise who had actually do it
in real life would do soon a mission
impossible but I thought it was so
inventive like Point Break does great
aerial stuff there are certain classic
aerial moments in movies and I think
this is amongst them I don't think Shane
black had built so much characterization
into this this downtrodden Iron Man at
this point you so want to see him save
the president you so want to see this
action work and you're so on the edge of
your seat and then it has a Twist so if
you can do all that and then of a Twist
that he wasn't in the suit and he was
doing it remotely genius because you're
on the edge of your seat and then when
things go awry he's been doing it
remotely genius use of the Iron Man suit
genius use of tension love this fight
action whatever you want to call it I
loved it all right number 14 we're going
back to Thanos now there's this thing in
the comics which they actually were able
to mirror more subtly until it was
obvious in front of me uh called The Big
Three Captain America Thor and Iron Man
are your big three those are the guys
that are often foundational for The
Avengers they are these characters that
are often at odds but often they will
always team up there they always
eventually get back together the big
three are a fascinating thing and the
big three against Thanos fight is so
incredible not only do you get
everything leading up to wielding
mjolnir but you get all of them fighting
as a team you've got the shield bouncing
off mjolnir you've got cap wielding
mjolnir you've got Iron Man throwing
everything he has at Thanos you also see
in that moment that three of her most
powerful warriors that at that point
we've already spent 12 13 years with
that we love can't take out this guy and
they're doing the best they've ever done
we're seeing such an intense powerful
Dynamic and I also love that it mirrors
The Avengers one moment where you see
them at odds with each other you see cap
fighting Thor you see all those things
and in this moment they're uniting
together and then it ends basically with
that that wielding of of mjolnir that we
all knew was coming this fight is so
emotionally impactful and it's so well
choreographed and it feels so real and
Thanos isn't real these ones in zeros so
it's very impressive this exists all
right I think this one is overshadowed
by some of the other action set pieces
will come up later in the list but I
feel like people don't talk about this
action set piece enough this is my
number 13 and it is the scene in
Bucharest in Civil War now obviously
you've got so many moving Parts there's
so many Dynamics here but to have a
fight go through a Stairway and then end
in a chase that is basically a
motorcycle winner soldier Captain
America black panther we just met Black
Panther and it's so definitely is able
to make us understand that he's right
alongside Captain America that he's
right alongside Winter Soldier that's
dream sequel stuff right there sequels
always feel like they have to get bigger
and bigger and then sometimes the bigger
and better doesn't work it doesn't feel
right this is doing a sequel to Winter
Soldier in a way that you're like oh man
black panther is just as hardcore as
these two we saw fighting in Winter
Soldier and the way they're able to play
at this Dynamic the way you feel for
Bucky now after falling in love with him
trying to get better and the way you
empathize with everyone in this Dynamic
that's the essence of Civil War it's
Heroes fighting each other it's people
that care about each other having to
come to blows and then the action's
insane when Bucky is able to like throw
that motorcycle over his shoulder like
hop on it Chase and then Black Panther's
just going it's awesome it is such a
cool set piece I love it so much all
right my number 12 is one of the most
violent things I think in the entirety
of the MCU it follows a certain iconic
hallway scene in season two of Daredevil
and it is a hallway of its own right but
how do you make a hallway for punisher
well you set it in a prison and it is
the essence of you're locked in here
with me and I love this sequence so much
because not only is it all the brutality
of the Punisher not only does it further
the story not only is it as ticking Time
Bomb leading to Kingpin but it gives us
the difference in the acrobatic
brutality of Daredevil opposite the
sheer brutality and blunt object just
hurt everyone of Punisher that then ends
with effectively a comic accurate moment
because the blood on his chest mirrors
the the bloody skull for the first time
we haven't gotten him in the skull yet
so we finally get the skull and it's in
the most brutal on brand to Netflix
Punisher way possible and it's through a
hallway this is the best of the comics
meets the best of these actors meets the
best of these stunties meets the best of
Netflix's a traditional always this is
everything in a fight and I love it so
much and it ends with Kingpin and
Punisher facing off could not have been
scripted in the Stars better love this
fight number 11 is incredible action
incredible characterization and a
beautiful way the fruit of the plot this
is what I like on my fights it is the
Prison Break scene in Guardians of the
Galaxy people remember how much they
love these characters people remember
how funny James Gunn's movies are but I
don't feel like they remember the action
ties so beautifully into the humor I
know the cosmic elements really changed
the MCU going forward but I really think
the team fight elements that are born
out of this very specific scene did
enhance and inspire a lot of stuff
coming up at The Avengers this is a
beautiful fight where they're all clad
together giving an almost uniform team
bonding feel which they hadn't had yet
so you got that characterization it also
culminates in rocket on Groot shoulder
and this insane 360 gun mowing down
while everything around them is moving
using Rocket's genius to build a bomb
using the cleverness of Pratt as star
Lord using Gamora there's so much of
this that all has to line up like a
great Heist like a great prison break I
love when a movie has like a ticking
clock that culminates an incredible
moment and that incredible moment
happens to also be the first time we
really see them as a team which mirrors
the first time we see the Avengers as a
team I love that spinning around shot I
always think of the Avengers uniting as
a team then James Gunn did it with the
Guardians United against the team added
an awesome gun and a Rocket Raccoon and
a group this seems just perfect so much
fun check it out again if you haven't
seen it in a while all right we are into
our top 10 MCU action scene fight set
pieces of all time and my number 10 is
maybe one of the more surprising endings
of a fight I honestly didn't see this
one coming the first time I saw this in
theaters there were gasps I remember
being shocked and so impressed that they
went this way it is the t'challa
killmonger fight on the waterfall that
ends with the mantle being past of the
Black Panther that is literally a
critical moment not just in the movie
but in the MCU understanding the passing
of the torch understanding the culture
of wakanda understanding how important
this battle is and then surprising us by
seemingly killing t'challa throwing him
off a waterfall which sets up a great
thing with umbaku and the tribe and
everything they're able to do there
which also grows out the world and then
the fight itself not only do you have
spectators that are that are rooting for
their King and feeling for their King
not only is it this beautiful Lush color
palette with all of Ruthie Carter's
costumes and this incredible visual of
this waterfall but you see and feel the
pain in the violence of killmonger you
understand as ever in this movie which
is so impressive where he's coming from
what he sees that he's fighting for and
at the same time you obviously are
rooting for t'challa the entire time I
love when fights have you going like man
I really understand where these guys are
coming from and then it lands in a way
that surprises you top 10 fight easy
incredible experience in theater I I
want to see this moment again on a big
screen tomorrow number nine is a recent
one and I honestly think it is a moment
that everyone thinks of when they think
of this movie which is the sign of a
good action set piece and it is one of
the moments that I I remember going like
oh I'm so glad the MCU can do this I'm
so glad they're going this way I'm so
glad practical is so important to them
in this set piece it's the bus scene in
shanxi the bus fight in shangshi is one
of the most captivating chases I've seen
in a car experience in a movie you've
got the dynamic of the hills in San
Francisco you've got this new character
with blades for hands you've got
shangchi who you've just really met and
you haven't seen him fight yet not
really and then you've got the
incredible ticking Time Bomb the tension
of aquafina's character that you're
trying to save you've got a fun tie-in
with the guy filming it you've got an
eye line through that guy filming it you
feel like you're there with him you've
got practical stunts you've got outside
the bus inside the bus Powers you've got
everything you could want in a comic
book adaptation fight and it's all going
60 miles apart a little bit more 77
miles per hour let's say it's going so
fast so intense this is the moment I
knew I love Chung Chi and this fight is
a big standout for me it's so honestly
hard once you're into the top I mean all
these have been hard but now we're in
the top eight I I really struggled with
each one of these positions so I'm going
to totally own that this number eight
was at one point number one that's how
much the top eight moved is this was my
number one and I love it and I think of
it probably weekly come at me nerds it
is the moment that I really really hoped
would transform how fights were and I
think we're working our way back to it
it is the elevator fight in Winter
Soldier this is close combat this isn't
shaky camp this is holding on stuff this
is showing the power of stunt people
this is furthering the plot the Betrayal
is literal and physical this is showing
what Captain America can do in a fight
we've seen him go up against superheroes
we've seen them like you know use your
Shields of battering iron we've seen a
lot of big we've seen a lot of
incredible things the match Rock Fight
by the way almost made this list it was
so hard not to just have 20 Winter
Soldier fights but batchrock showed us
what he could do with that Dynamic with
open space I loved bringing it in tight
making it intense I love that we see
crossbones really born here I love that
he's fighting some of his you know
mercenary compatriots which is also a
commentary in the whole movie he's
fighting against the system the system's
betraying him and I also love that we
all love it so much that when they
brought it back an end game that moment
was immediately like oh this is one of
the best action pieces in movies I love
the elevator fight so very all right
again this top eight any of these could
be number one and this one is maybe the
fight I talked about most on the entire
press tour for this film I went to
London with this film I talked to the
director on this film I talked to the
stars in this film I was very invested
in this fight on this film to the point
where I then ran into the director on
the no way home tour and he remembered
how excited it was about this fight and
that was years later and that guy talks
to probably 100 people a day my love for
this fight is so loud that he was like
oh you're the guy that loved the
Mysterio fight and far from home was
literally a John romita Senior sequence
mixed with a John romita Jr sequence
come to life John Amita senior one of
the best Spider-Man artists of all time
his son John meter Jr another of the
best Spider-Man artist of all time
mixing a little bit of Ross Andrew that
is what this fight felt like I felt like
I was a kid reading a comic book
flipping pages and my imagination was
actually translated on screen I talk all
the time about adaptation versus
translation there are times in short
sports that an adaptation totally works
because it furthers the story it fits
the medium and it reminds you why you
love the meaning of comics while
reminding you why you love the medium of
movies that's the sequence you also got
a little dash of Iron Man zombie you
also got some incredibly surrealistic
images that make you a little afraid
it's it's heart-wrenching and it builds
the overall Six movie Arc of Spider-Man
in that the spider sense becomes so
essential here I love that the spider
sense is developed over time like his
origin I love that Mysterio is a
prophetic villain because we're going to
be dealing with deep fakes and voice
modulation and all the issues that are
coming in our reality and Mysterio shows
that in a very at an 11 Superhero scope
way with this fight I would change not a
single frame of this fight I love it so
much the Mysterio fight is one of my
favorite sequences in any comic book
movie ever alright number six and this
one I think people have found on off of
because of how long it's been I think a
lot of times people get like ah that was
before and they don't remember what it
felt like then how inventive it was then
how important it was then and I think
that you need to look at uh the
influence of things as well as the
current technology and this one holds up
and is arguably my favorite Hulk fight
in the entire MCU it is The Avengers
Assemble in the battle for New York it
is giving us that first team spin around
it is giving us every single character
that we've seen in five different movies
uniting for the first time it seems easy
now it seems very like oh right get
these characters before Avengers no one
thought it was possible before Avengers
came out people were like you're gonna
have the guy from that Mythic Norse God
movie team up with the guy from that
World War II movie and the guy that made
like a suit it didn't make sense this
battle for New York showed us that you
can make all these different tones come
together it showed us that all these
characters fighting styles are
beautifully worked for a team Dynamic it
gave us again the visual of the Avengers
assembling is such a moment moment and
it still makes me excited it still fills
my my heart with Glee and it actually
made things feel like there was a scope
right like New York was actually losing
like people were dying it was intense it
was real and it set the stage for Iron
Man's PTSD it set the stage for so many
important elements that launched out of
the MCU this was a moment that that
spawned so many moments and it did it
beautifully with brilliant action I love
love love battle for New York all right
we are into the top five my lovelies and
how do you top an Avenger assemble even
if they don't say it yet how do you make
a fight against the chatari seem like
nothing you have them fight each other
every punch lands twice if you care
about both people fighting I say that
all the time and I don't think that's
ever been more true since the first
double page spread come to life Captain
America Civil War gave us the airport
fight which is one for the ages I get a
lot of crap for defending Civil War I
maintain it's in the top maybe eight
Marvel films of all time I think it is
so good consist and Powerful the villain
berenzemo does this with words he gets
the strongest people on the planet
instead of fighting them he makes them
fight each other in his reasoning behind
it is is sound if not like a completely
unreasonable there's so much right about
how this fight happens how long it takes
to get there and then how much they let
you live there this fight's Wicked long
it was unprecedented this is like a
chunk of the movie and you've got
everything from giant man for the first
time to Spider-Man for the first time to
Black Panther for the first time you've
got so many beautiful images the moment
we all saw Spider-Man land with Captain
America's shield and he says hey
everyone that's all the marketing this
movie ever needed and it was a Lion's
Share of this movie's marketing and
that's just the tip of the iceberg we've
got scale with throwing insane things
we've got the tiniest little things
being important we've got characters
having the banter they do from the comic
books we've got people meeting for the
first time every kid that group reading
comics is like who would win in a fight
on the playground this is the playground
they made the playground in airport
which is also genius because it gets rid
of a lot of the the problem that DC was
having at the time where lots of people
are dying and abandoned airport is
perfect everything about this is is
exactly T's crossed eyes dotted
excitement and I love it so much and I
still think about those two teams of
Avengers how that might have gone if
they went different ways and one was New
Avengers like they teased at the end
anyway that's another whole video I love
it so much rewatch The Civil War fight
do yourself a favor it's like
Thanksgiving did all right number four
again any of these could be number one
number four is maybe the loudest I've
cheered in the theater I try not to be
the guy that collaps when planes land
and sometimes it feels like that guy in
a theater but this was pure emotionality
I like cheering in a theater I like
being a part of that I go to the movie
theater for a reason it feels like
Community this was one of the most
Community Driven moments I've ever
experienced in a theater because we've
been upset for two and a half hours our
guys have lost for two and a half hours
we are now in wakanda with wakanda's
Last Stand as all of our heroes have
rallied together and then Thor lands
fully powered as the god of lightning
with a new weapon Stormbreaker set to
Immigrant Song and then just proceeds to
own we've got incredible fights again
using the The Genius of the just running
just the visual of running I talked
about it earlier in the Civil War fight
but here we've got Captain America and
Black Panther running through this crowd
to lead I love that they're now side by
side and they're doing it to lead this
Army to take out these Invaders this
feels like a comic book to such a level
the soundtrack's incredible the action
is dynamic it is so visually stunning it
is so powerful and then there's moments
of levity that don't feel like too much
levity the thing I'm struggling with in
phase four is as much as I love humor
sometimes I'm like it's a little
misplaced and I had that with earlier
too like Age of Ultron there are moments
when I don't feel like Age of Ultron is
as intimidating like Ultron will crack a
joke which I understand it's a Tony
Stark spin-off it makes sense for the
character too but there's moments where
it doesn't make sense tonally to this
fight as some of the best totally
accurate jokes like when they're when
they're fighting and you have Steve
Rogers meet group for the first time and
he's like I am Groot and then Steve
Rogers is like I am Steve Rogers genius
it makes sense it elevates the tone it
gives you a minute to breathe and then
you get back to the melee perfect fight
perfect moments God I love this fight
number three Infinity war and end game
are back to back they shot him at the
same time they came out very close
together they are one giant experience
how do you top The wakandan Last Stand
how do you top the moment with Immigrant
Song and the landing and that intensity
how do you go from 14 years since this
world started to have anything that
feels like a justifiable conclusion to a
climax to a fight how do you do a fight
big enough that you're like this feels
right you finally say Avengers Assemble
and then you open up portals and every
character ever except the Netflix
characters which is a real stream comes
out of those portals and they all just
go to town for like 20 minutes
you've got thanos's entire cabal you've
got the shatari you've got everything
tying all of this together in this one
it's basically like a screensaver you
zoom out and see and it's after Steve
Rogers has decided he's going to do it
himself we get the ultimate essence of
who Steve Rogers is he's one man
standing by himself wielding mjolnir
like a boss ready to take on the entire
Army until he dies because he can do
this all day but then he doesn't have to
we get the result of people coming back
from the snap we see characters we lost
we haven't seen Again by way of the
portal we here on your left to kick this
fight off coming from Anthony Mackey who
is now Captain America mirroring that
magical comedic moment again levity in
the right place mirroring that from
winter soldiers who use a joke to
further emphasis it's not even a joke in
that case but it's using a past joke to
really drive a moment home and you've
got all these characters you love on
screen at once for the first time and
then you hear uh one of the most iconic
two words in comic books uttered for the
first time this moment is like
I mean it's like really nothing else
Avengers Assemble and the fight that
ensued after and the scope of the
visuals of what the universe was built
that's what it is that moment in a fight
is zooming out at all your Blu-rays in a
stack that's looking at 30 Blu-rays
stacked up and going like they've built
this and giving you that moment that
you've dreamed of since you were a kid
Avengers Assemble and that's only number
three we got two more to go number two
is gonna be I probably probably a little
controversial because we just went from
Avengers Assemble but that's kind of my
point this again top eight could have
all been number one this fight to me is
the strength of the MCU in that smaller
is sometimes better I love The Avengers
Assemble fight but when I think about it
I'm remembering moments little pieces I
don't have like a play-by-play because
it's too much your brain it's not
retainable I like grounded Marvel
arguably more than giant Marvel I like
street level arguably more than Cosmic I
like characters that I'm invested in
both sides of the fight again why I love
uh Civil War obviously we want Thanos
and his guys to go you're not you don't
want you have no inner conflict with
that fight the knife fight in Winter
Soldier is not only Bucky showing that
he can take out both Black Widow and
Captain America which seems insane we
just met this guy but it's actually the
actors fighting with a knife hand to
hand showing not only the power of stunt
performers but also the power of these
actors it's showing their power set it's
showing that the Russo Brothers can
direct the hell out of an action
sequence I think arguably this sequence
is what got them Avengers Infinity war
in endgame because it furthers the
character development furthers the
greater MCU and what impact this is it
shows you what a real comic book fight
can look like when you're locked in on
it there is again no what's going on is
that CGI this is a brutal fight between
Brothers this is Steve Rogers fighting
Winter Soldier and then realizing it's
Bucky in this fight so you've got that
emotional turning point it's Black Widow
who we've seen just be so formidable get
taken out very quickly and it's all
after this incredible action scene with
Nick Fury in one of the better car
chases in the MCU so your heart's
already racing and then you dive into
this it's a great offensive and
defensive use of The Shield it's just
everything I love about a good fight
sequence and it feels contained and I
love that I can just be in on it I can
play that entire fight scene in my head
straight through it is my number two it
is everything I want to fight scene to
be here we are number one all right so I
broke a rule here Greg was like we gotta
keep it to the MCU otherwise this list
will be too long but I snuck in a fox
property I want you to remember when the
rain is falling Evanescence plays and
you're like man Daredevil is gonna be
the best fight scene of all time and
then I want to remember the Heartbreak
cause Daredevil has the best scene of
all time in the Netflix version that
came out 10 years later and it is still
the best action I have ever seen from
Marvel this changed fight scenes can you
imagine being hired to do a daredevil
show I'm gonna talk about Chris Brewster
here Chris Brewster is the man in the
suit in this fight sequence can you
imagine dedicating your life to martial
arts being this incredible martial
artist that loves Comics investing in
this character putting your Blood Sweat
and Tears into it and then doing that
job which is largely one take and being
like that's really gonna have an impact
on people comic fans are gonna love this
and then zoom out and every network has
copied it it has established a
fingerprint for Netflix it is changed
comic book movies and shows they did
such a good job that stunt team that
stunt performer what what Brewster did
alongside Charlie Cox what Charlie Cox
was able to do in using the mask to lean
and position and using doorways to tag
in and out stunt people so a lot of the
time it is Charlie Cox and then they
they're literal ninjas it's a ninja
fight scene that has ninjas doing the
fights you care about every impact you
are invested in every camera angle its
Elegance is it Simplicity and its
Simplicity is very complicated I love
when a fight scenes like oh that's
they're fighting the hallway but it's so
complex and Powerful this made the
Netflix Universe this one hallway fight
is the thing you think of and it's the
bar that every MCU fight sense has had
this is a Netflix show it didn't have a
250 million dollar budget and to this
day when you think about a movie with a
250 million dollar budget the hallway
fight is the bar that's just so
incredible the hallway change Cinema
hard stop it is the best action scene in
the MCU and I'm so happy that even if
you don't like Comics you understand
what we feel sometimes when we read them
that was what it feels like to feel that
adrenaline that action that intensity
and they gave us that in 3D they gave us
that in in one of the most memorable
action scenes of all time that is my
number one alright you lovelies that is
gonna do it that is my top 25 action
scenes in the MCU again we only used MCU
and Netflix MCU as in the ones that have
the characters that are all
interchanging I understand that now we
have Andrew Garfield and Toby McGuire in
the MCU I saw no way home I talk about
it quite a bit but it didn't make sense
to really add those into this video if
you want to see what I think of those
Marvel fights do you want to know what I
thought of the train scene with Doc Ock
do you want to know what I thought of
the Logan brutality of the opening of
Logan do you want to know what I thought
of the first Berserker rage next to I
can do all of that just leave a comment
let me know we got to get this video to
50 000 so like subscribe send it to your
friends comment it all drives up the
algorithm let's hit 50k and I will do a
15 or 20 of the Marvel fights maybe even
get some Ghost Rider in there because
what Neville Dean and Taylor were able
to do with cinematography they were on
roller skates behind cars there's
craziness we will do the MCU and then
this is done Marvel and you know blade
Blood Rave is gonna be on that because
that blade Blood Rave I think about it
all the time I listen to the soundtrack
like an inordinate amount do you find
yourself just bopping to 90s techno I
hope you do all right that is going to
do it your lovelies like subscribe
comment find me on Tick Tock harass Greg
so we can make that next list and most
of all go read a comic book Thank you
thank you thank you I'll see you next
time
[Music]